dans pourquoi on dit je vous raconte ce
qui se cache derrière les expressions de
la langue française alors abonnez vous
et n'oubliez pas que je suit loge salue
les épis curieuse et les épis curieux
pourquoi dit-on passer du coq à l'âne
[Musique]
cette expression signifie changer de
sujet ou d'idées sans transition ou sans
suite logique ce que nous allons éviter
justement pour comprendre d'où vient
cette expression mais pourquoi le coquil
dans cette dame il ne s'agit
probablement pas à l'origine du cousin
du cheval l'âne qui s'écrit avec un
accent circonflexe sur le a
mais plutôt de l'âne sans chapeau sur la
première lettre
un mot qui au moyen âge désignait la can
la femelle du canal près celle sur
laquelle on s'appuie l'expression de mes
donc s'entendre plutôt comme sauter du
coq à la can d'un animal à l'autre
qu'ils n'avaient rien à voir
il s'agissait aussi parfois de se moquer
du code qui pouvait aller jusqu à
courtiser la cades qui n'a rien à voir
évidemment avec la poule avec le temps
le mot and désignant la can a disparu
mais l'expression passer du coq à l'âne
est resté hans écrivant avec un accent
circonflexe comme le mot désignant le
cousin aux grandes oreilles du cheval si
vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à laisser un pouce bleus merci les épis
curieux pour les plus gourmands en voici
d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]